[Music]
it is time once again for our puppy pig
skin picks courtesy of subaru and the
animal foundation
john is with us we have an intern here
holding our dog uh
john why don't you tell us about this uh
beautiful dog this is apricot
he's two years old he's about 15 pounds
he came in as a stray so we don't have a
background on him
but he's extremely shy you can't tell
that right now
but he needs somebody to love him out of
his shell and that's why we have our
intern here helping out
uh and how long have you had uppercut
for the shelter for about a week
yeah but friendly obviously just kind of
shot yeah very friendly very sweet just
just extremely shy
okay understood well apricot now that
the time is
is upon us here well you'll have to make
your choice between
the atlanta falcons and your las vegas
raiders
uh intern if you wouldn't mind putting
apricot down let's see
what apricot chooses here apricot
chooses the raiders yay
thanks john thanks apricot thanks
raiders thanks subaru
and the animal foundation thank you very
much
you gotta sort out that intern situation
if you would like to adopt apricot just
call the animal foundation the number is
on your screen 955-5901
you do have to make an appointment
though to see a pet and i feel like many
people will want to see apricot alex
okay
that dog was the cutest thing i almost
ran off with apricot
so i'm sure he won't be there long if
you're interested so sweet